tonight is my it's my pleasure to well
John path cow back to the podium in
Hastings Hall
this is John's third time around as Lord
Norman our foster visiting professor in
architecture together with Patricia Pat
cow a 1978 graduate of our school who is
his professional and life partner John
Pat Cal weeds one of Canada's most
respected practices with offices located
in Vancouver the foster chair was
endowed by the by Norman Foster and his
family Norman is a 1962 graduate of our
school as many of you know and he has
always been an outstanding model for
excellence in our profession on many
occasions Lord foster has acknowledged
his debt to Yale to the great teachers
he encountered here in particular Paul
Rudolph searched Tamiya and Vincent
Scully and in his own words his death to
the studio atmosphere which was highly
creative competitive with the kind of
can-do approach that is influenced and
inspired his practice for more than 40
years the foster chair is intended to
attract top teaching talent to our
studios our advanced studios and in
particular to ensure the continuing
presence at Yale of international
visiting faculty yes Canada is a foreign
country it is a profession in a
profession known for shameless
self-promotion John and Patricia Pat Cal
standout for excellence quietly pursued
known for its meticulous attention to
the craft of building Pat cow architects
convincingly address a wide variety of
programs and scales from luxurious
private residences to large complexes
for education and health
long before the idea of sustainability
became embedded as a hallmark of
Responsible architecture the pack out
studio approached its work with an
environmental sensitivity that was
deeply
and but never stridently promoted
subsumed as it was into a commitment to
architecture as a comprehensive
enterprise that only really succeeds
when it rises to the level of art john
patka holds a Bachelor of Arts Bachelor
of Environmental Studies and Master of
Architecture from the University of
Manitoba he is taught at the University
of British Columbia since 1985 and has
been a visiting professor at Washington
University in st. Louis and at Harvard
where together with Patricia Pascal
he was Elliot noise professor in 1995 in
spring 2009 he was Eero Saarinen
visiting professor here at Yale in
thrinng 2011 and for 2012 he was foster
professor a chair he once again holds
please join me in welcoming John PATCO
as he reviews the work in his
partnership originally titled recent
work that was a clever original title
but now retitled work play John
Thank You Dean soon pleasure to be back
at Yale Dean this term I'd like to
present a number of projects this
evening in which my partner Richard and
I have been engaged in the last few
years they this is a sort of us it's not
a survey it's a few selected projects
from the recent past and I've decided to
divide the lecture into two parts the
first a series of building projects
obviously commissioned by clients but
the second a series of research projects
which in the main we initiated ourselves
and I've as the insert mentioned I have
changed the title of the lecture and
I've changed the title to work play to
reflect the strong duality in the nature
of the two types of projects both in
terms of their intention and in terms of
their circumstance and I should say that
the research component of the of the
work that I'm showing is a very serious
endeavor in the office we perhaps not
the office in totality but certainly
Patricia and I spend a significant part
of our time investigating these projects
they I think contributed enormous ly to
New Directions in our work and so I'd
like to begin with some building
projects and get oriented here and I
should say that the the building
projects are characterized by some
ongoing concerns which have been part of
our work for quite a long time we've
been in practice for thirty years now
and have these concerns have sort of
evolved over time from the outset we
looked at what we called the found
potential of a project as a point of
departure by that we meant the Aspen
those aspects of site climate building
context program or local culture that
would facilitate the development of an
architectural form which was evocative
of circumstance the result of this
approach is that individual projects
often take on distinct
in response to differing circumstance
and consequently the formal relationship
between our projects is loose at best to
us this is an appropriate expression of
the diversity within which we live with
time we've come to understand that
architecture arises from this diversity
of circumstantial considerations only
through a synthetic act of imagination
this act of imagination is it also can
take many forms for us most commonly an
expression of cultural purpose of
environmental response and of
construction and technology the more
inclusive the imagination is to the
diversity of circumstances which
surround the project the more complete
the work of architecture and then there
is the issue of craft for us craft is
intellectual in the first instance it is
a construction of ideas a rigorous set
of relationships which form an armature
for the ongoing development and
elaboration of the project craft is also
aesthetic the product of the sensibility
of mine and I and finally craft is
physical the material product of mind
and hand and the hands extension through
technology like the act of imagination
from which the architectural project is
formed I believe the more inclusive the
craft the more complete the work of
architecture so I'm going to begin the
building projects with the presentation
of three houses I presented these houses
as projects previously I'm now going to
present them as completed projects and I
believe that they in their diversity
represent the nature of our practice
than the fact that there is this strong
response to circumstance which forms a
strong differentiation between projects
and so the first project is on an island
just off the west coast of British
Columbia salt spring island which is a
very temperate place beautiful climate
very much like Northern California the
site is a farm a very small farm which
you see circled on the aerial photograph
didn't plan here you can see the the
configuration which is largely a hay
meadow and I'm going to try and make
this so what we have here is a residual
line of fir trees these are massive use
this much better
okay these are fully mature Douglas fir
trees which are a residual part of the
evergreen forest that used to cover the
island below there is a cottage barn a
few buildings including a studio and a
cultural landscape which has been
constructed by a German resident who
subsequently sold the property to my
clients which is characterized by fruit
trees by trees imported from Europe by a
really a very eclectic cultural
landscape so our approach was to try and
find some way of organizing this larger
site and introducing a larger new house
to the project and we did that by first
of all taking the existing house and
selling it to the neighbor up the road
and just moved it down the road and then
inserted the new house which is
comprised of two parts a main house and
a guest house and it has a very unusual
proportion it's 280 feet long and the
interior dimension is 16 feet so the
aspect ratio of this house is extreme
and then finally we reinforced the
cultural landscape by developing the
orchard and a much more intensive way
the clients were very food oriented and
very garden oriented so there was a
significant program of reinforcing the
cultural program here you see the plan
in various forms the roof plan the
reflective season plan and the floor
plan and a couple of things that jump
out one is obviously the aspect ratio
this extremely elongated plan where the
rooms are simply lined up as a series of
rooms
but if you look at the roof plan you can
see that there are 40 skylights in the
roof and the majority of these skylights
do not penetrate into the interior
they simply illuminate the building
envelope the the roof assembly of this
house and I was explained briefly why
that is so and then there is there are
very significant apertures which are
completely opening so this is a an
aperture that 78 feet clear span which
is fully retractable the climate here is
extremely benign during the summertime
the temperatures are run in the mid to
high 70s all the time there's virtually
no rain and so the house opens up like a
pavilion so here is the building section
and you can see that the interior is
held away with a significant different
distance to the exterior portion of the
envelope and there are skylights which
shine into this void space what that
does is illuminate a translucent plastic
interior so the interiors that you will
see are not drywall which you might
think by looking at them briefly but
they're actually all translucent plastic
so here is the interior elevation of the
long opening and here is the opening in
actuality so the last wall has been
retracted into the sides the roof
assembly is skylit and so the
translucent plastic glows in patches not
only the patches of lights at the base
of the fir trees and the entire interior
opens up to the surrounding exterior
both to the native fir trees which are
on the south or on the north rather and
the cultural garden on the south so here
the house is located in the context of
those very large fir trees second growth
since the Second World War which shows
you how quickly trees grow in British
Columbia and the house itself is
characterized by a very dark color which
is intended to make it disappear into
the shadows of the tree
details such as these screen walls are
used to pull out the quality of light
and the changing light conditions as
they move through the time of day and
also act as a screen where the retracted
glass walls are stored and so the
opening from the exterior the ends of
the house have extremely extended
cantilever this is a wood framed house
the 78 foot span is a would span the 26
foot cantilever is on the end are wood
cantilevers
so there's from a wood construction
point of view it's an interesting and
quite ambitious structure on the south
side you have a walkway which connects
the guest house and the main house the
cultural garden is to the right there
are similar openings on this side which
look through to the fir trees on the
other side of the house this is actually
an oven there are four ovens in this
house because of the interest of the
clients in food and cooking and again
you can see the interior is illuminated
by the light shining through the
skylights into the building assembly
see the similar effect after dark the
2x4 framing is evident through this
translucent skin again the shower opens
up to the exterior to some Austrian
Sycamore trees the passage between the
main house and the guest portion of the
house and the guest bedrooms with loft
spaces and again the effect of the light
shining through the building envelope
the second house and I should say that
the three houses that are showing we're
all designed in roughly the same period
of time and so they reflect our
preoccupations at a single moment and
show the great variety of circumstances
within which we're working so this is
located on another Island this is a
northern island so it has a much more
extreme and violent climate than the
house that i apprec--
it's on Quadra Island which is just
where the Strait of Georgia becomes a
myriad of islands and if you know the
west coast the sailing in this area is
truly spectacular the house is located
on a very complex site there is Rock
Mound the gates which the house is
located on the North phenomenal panorama
of Ocean to the east tidal pool to the
south and a maple and fir forest to the
to the east or to the west rather and
here is the condition of the view toward
the toward the east and the fifth view
we have often called this project the
five site project the fifth portion of
the site which was very important in the
conception of the design is the beach
below the site which is littered with
the debris that the storms bring onto
the onto the rock outcroppings
and so there are floats and nets that
come off of fishing boats there are the
logs that are have been lost at sea with
the logging industry and even boulders
which get thrown up onto this Beach and
the beach is constantly being
reorganized with every storm and so the
spatial idea of the house begins with
the mound and the forest and the
panorama to the east entering the site
from deep inland you move along the edge
of the rock outcropping and through a
series of spaces which are defined by
low rock walls and then there is
inserted a series of concrete walls
which channel the space through what
will be the house and out to the ocean
various sort of Eddy like spaces which
are around the main flow space become
the service basins and bedrooms the
kitchen and things of that nature that
Center space gets filled with debris
like the debris in the V on the beach
below shards of concrete patches of
water elements of furniture and finally
a deck which is cantilevered off the
rock cliff beyond the face of the rock
toward the ocean and the plan itself and
so the private rooms are all true this
is a view from the rock cliff above the
house the roof is an extension of that
surface
they're often deer on the roof it really
functions as as a continuity of that
surface entering into the first part
which is the auto part where you bring
and leave your cars you have access to
the space that we're in here which is a
carport the climate is very again very
moderate and so it's not from the winter
rainstorms the only need really is for
cover
and then moving through into the next
space which is the space you walk into
to enter the house and here you begin to
be aware of the interior spaces within
the house the walkway along the bedrooms
that takes you from the carport to the
main house looking through the channel
of space all the way out to the ocean
beyond various elements such as the rock
wall which Peters out in this space the
building is clad entirely in a charcoal
colored fabric panel which has been
organized so that each panel is legible
and then into the house itself which is
organized around a large dining room but
it's not just a dining room the clients
have a foundation which is dedicated to
environmental issues and so this is also
a meeting space this is a meeting house
as well as a residence in fact
surprisingly the clients live here in
the wintertime and go further north in
the summer because the weather is too
nice and so spinning off of this space
you enter into the kitchen which
overlooks the toilet pool back through
the space each of the concrete walls and
I should say that the people who built
this house had never built architectural
concrete before and they built the best
architecture concrete I've ever seen
it's just remarkable workmanship and
each of the concrete walls is projected
through the roof as a skylight which you
see here and so moving into the bedroom
areas to gain absolutely meticulous
construction the bedrooms themselves are
all oriented low to either the rock
mound which is to the north or this
bedroom which is the third bedroom which
is slightly rotated overlooking the
forest descending down to the beach
small spaces all of these surfaces are
acoustic surfaces so that even though
the interior the house
is very hard materials the acoustic
quality of the space is very soft
because the ceiling is entirely
absorptive so here you are looking over
georgia straight back to the mainland of
british columbia there is even pieces of
glass in the floor these are extremely
large double glazed glass panes which
are inserted into the floor which give
you access to the beach below which is
particularly amazing during the storms
which throw all sorts of things up onto
the beach another piece of glass on the
floor and behind this projecting
concrete wall is a small study space
and then moving through to the water
side of the house you can see here how
the house is projected over the face of
the rock the glass openings that were in
the floor here the decks on either end
are what you see with the wood deck
material to illustrate how remote this
house is you'll note that there's not
another single light in this image and
that's not Photoshop there just are no
dwellings in that area this is the only
house in that entire stretch of land
which holds a significant construction
challenge because it's an extremely
remote location so the last house a game
designed at this at a similar time is in
Whistler British Columbia which is as
you probably know a ski resort enormous
amounts of snow 15 feet of snow and the
winter is not unusual and so the house
is in many ways shaped by it it's
located in surprising you know in a
subdivision right here
very tough context for us by virtue of
the character of the adjacent dwellings
but also by virtue of the real estate
imperative of Whistler which is that
land prices are very high and the owner
wanted to maximize the sort of the
development and so the heart instruction
was very simple he wanted the biggest
house that was legally possible to
achieve on the property that posed the
obvious issues of fitting it into the
building envelope but more challenging
in Whistler is the need to design a
house which sheds snow in two locations
where people and cars are not located
and so the roof is designed in a way to
push snow around so that it doesn't go
into the areas where people and they and
vehicles are and this was from a design
point of view a new investigation for us
it was a completely three-dimensional
project the second house I showed you on
Quadra Island has a very complex plan
geometry but beyond that it's fairly
conventional this house was developed to
maximize volume we designed it entirely
in small card models and so what you see
here is an array of the models that we
use to develop a volume once we had
developed a design we developed a set of
digital drawings and then we printed the
digital drawings to see how closely the
digital representation matched the card
models and once we were satisfied that
it was a good match we proceeded with
that and so this is the final digital
model of the project there is virtually
except for some interior walls there are
no vertical walls in the project and
aside from the floors and even some of
them are sloping there are no horizontal
surfaces in the project and so framing
this project became undocumented it
became a significant challenge it was
only possible because of our ability to
work in 3d and the ability of certain
trades to construct in 3d and in that
regard the host was framed
in terms of its principle members with
steel and heavy timber construction
which both of which industries are
probably the most developed in terms of
three-dimensional geometry and so they
were able to sort of stitch out the
basic configuration of the house within
which there was a wood structure in
field we made a few mistakes where we
felt that the we didn't need heavy
timber or steel we framed those areas in
conventional wood framing and getting
those geometries right was almost
impossible the contractor really
struggled we came to understand that it
would have been a much better investment
to do the entire project as a sort of a
steel or accommodation steel and glulam
frame
to simplify the construction process and
so the houses is is constructed with a
concrete box which allows a significant
cantilever out over the slope because
it's on a sloping site above which there
is a frame which creates the upper
structure with wood infill and within
the middle of which is a sort of a tall
rift space which runs through the
project to bring light into the center
of the project and so here you see the
building sections this is the house
cantilevering out over the slope below
it's in sometimes the snow up here it's
designed for enormous slow low the snow
loads and so the structure is
unbelievably robust images of it again
this volume was constructed principally
to maximize the interior space available
within the zoning envelope that was
provided the again there was a local
bylaw which required that the building
be clad in wood this is a IPE which is
not a native British Columbia wood but
the only wood that was durable enough to
both be walls and roof and so the roof
assembly is similar to the wall assembly
and it's capable of dealing with
enormous snow loads geometry is again as
I say is extremely complex the
workmanship again was was exceptional
there seems to be a tremendous body of
craftsmen available in British Columbia
for projects of this kind moving into
the interior the interior spaces in some
ways our resultant spaces of the dictum
to maximize building volume but they're
all very carefully formed to construct
the right kind of emphasis and to
I make the right kind of relationships
to the surrounding context and there's a
very long bridge which spans from the
master bedroom which is entered at this
point across to the study which is
located here the and then finally the
study and in areas such as this where we
overlook a neighbor the wood screen runs
right over the windows but has been
serrated to construct a more transparent
area and so I think that the fact that
those represent those three houses which
most I think people wouldn't recognize
as coming from the same office but all
reflect our interests are really driven
by the response that we're making to not
only the environmental circumstances of
the project but the cultural
circumstances of the project I also
showed two projects or three projects so
in my last lecture at Yale which were
competitions that we had won two of them
have subsequently been constructed or
they've just been completed this fall
and so I'm going to show those the first
is in Fort York national historic site
visitors seit Center in Toronto Fort
York is historical fort from the late
17th and 1800s it was the site of
important battle which between the
Americans and the British which
instigated the bridge raid on Washington
which resulted in the burning of the
White House which was Canada's only
major war accomplishment the fort itself
is extremely modest endeavor it was
constructed in the late 1700s
it was located at the edge of a garrison
Creek on the narrow
Prado Harbor which was in York and now
is mning below a freeway
about 500 meters from the water so the
entire waterfront has been filled in and
this I what was just a little finger of
land has been filled in for a Municipal
Airport the result is that a space which
is viewed as being the origin of the
City of Toronto is now a small forgotten
place underneath the freeway very
challenging location and the the
intention of which was to somehow
reintroduce this fort to the city and to
make it accessible and and acknowledge
the importance that it has as part of
local history and so here is the fort
the space that we're standing and
looking toward the fort is called the
common and this is the site of the
battle between the British and the
Americans the fort is protected by worms
and there are some buildings inside a
very very sort of modest effort where
basically it really is a small mediation
between the two forces that are engaged
in the battle site characterized by sort
of a fluid rolling landscape and that
sort of fluidity that kind of almost a
pastoral landscape and the fact that
this was at one time on the shore of
Lake Ontario were important aspects in
the development of the project and so
the first thing that we decided to do
was to construct an edge there is a
slope of land in this location and this
is the only part the the freeway is not
shown in this drawing but the freeway is
actually running right along here this
is the former girlfriend and so the
notion is that we would reconstruct the
edge both of the in a metaphorical way
both of the lake and of the fort and so
here is our site not the most auspicious
of sites and this is the beginning of
one of the sketches from the competition
sort of the idea of
a barricade a long palisade of
weathering steel panels behind which and
below grade below the common above the
visitors center would be located and so
the plan is this is the pathway of the
freeway which is running through here
the building is located in the zone
between the freeway and the undisturbed
soil above the undisturbed soil above is
an archeological site which is being
worked and the only place in which we
could locate the building without
interfering with the archeological site
was in the soil of the freeway
construction so basically that that part
of the site that was disturbed by the
construction of the freeway is where we
located the building the building as I
said is basically subterranean located
below the here this is freeway this is
the extension of the common with and
then the space below the freeway is part
of a very important series of spaces in
Toronto right now which is the subject
of great deal of discussion because of
the fact that the this freeway cuts off
the lakeshore from the city and has
significant spaces with them under it
and so one of the important things that
the project began to address is how to
occupy that space and turn it into a
positive public space and so we decided
that we would reinvent this space as a
metaphor of the lake its planted out in
grasses and irises and water related
plants and has within it walkways and
large decks for outdoor events which are
raised above the existing grade so that
if they're almost dark light in their
construction and so here you see one of
the images from the perspective of the
visitor center wherever there are large
openings the weathering steel panels
have been tipped up into space and the
space below the freeway has been
developed
to an important public space the plan
which I won't go into in detail has a
major lobby it has a variety of
multi-purpose rooms not only as a
visitor center for the fort it is also a
community center for the local
population and so it has a lot of
multi-purpose uses but there is also an
important exhibit space which is too
extreme gallery standards which are
located here and an administration area
for the operation of the fort one of the
interesting things about the brief that
the of the competition was that there
was to be what was described as a time
tunnel which would lead you from the
visitor center to the fort and in our
project we proposed to develop a ramp
that would run through an audio-visual
experience and take you from the lower
level within the visitor center up to
the upper level of the common what you
see here to the upper level again in
section here what we found that was that
there was another possibility which
which was that this would become a scrim
on to which our visual could be
projected to represent events of the
history of the fort but also to support
other public events well we won the
competition and actually this is the
plan leading you up and back to the fort
and the project was delayed for a while
and then ultimately we began to develop
it and we have finally just constructed
the core of the project which you see
here so this is the beginning of the
weathering steel embankment there are
extensions which are yet to be
constructed on either side the
foreground which will
be landscaped and have these large
raised plazas for events will be coming
the hole for next year the scrim and
projection is a victim of the budget
struggles that we had on the project and
even the fact that the project is
currently incomplete in terms of the
landscape and the interior development
is a function of some of the budget
struggles we had but Toronto has was
blessed by the presence of Rob Ford as
mayor tenure and so it was it was it was
an interesting experience emerging as a
long triangular Channel glass facade but
here the to make connections either to
the comment above or to the building
interior these are eight feet by twenty
four foot by three-quarter inch thick
weathering steel panels which are either
clipped onto the face of the building or
are supported on beams and a large
torsional member which you can see
phenomenal material it there is such
material presence and gravity to this
and surprisingly we the opening was a
better month and a half ago and so isin
lead the public reaction to this
material which I was concerned about has
been extremely positive so that's pretty
interesting
this is was in a week at the time of the
photograph but it's a combination of sea
grasses viruses and things of that
nature
temporary
some of the spaces which are opened by
virtue of the rotated steel panels and
then the interior which has yet to be
where the installations have yet to be
complete the lobby the beginning of the
access to the time tunnel
time tunnel rising above the major
gallery space the second competition
which we went and these were at the same
time is also in Toronto and it's at the
University of Toronto and it was a
hybrid project which combined the
Goldring Center for high-performance
sport and a student Commons for the
University and so there was within it
Fieldhouse to support high level
basketball and volleyball important
strength and conditioning center major
research component as well as a student
center which represented another of the
large spaces within the interior and it
has a very interesting site it's located
across the very small street which is
closed for events from varsity Stadium
which is the the track and field and
football stadium for the University and
varsity stadium has a grandstand on one
side only and so the notion is that we
would construct spaces which would take
advantage of the openness on the west
side of the field for overlook and so
here is the situation there is a
pedestrian Lane kind of walkway along
here Street that can be closed important
cross connections through our site a
future tower which I'll talk about in a
while which we're currently developing
on the north end of the
and so here was the university's
expectation there would be large
basketball volleyball field s which
would have two courts one of which is a
competition court and and in practice
board the other it's strictly a practice
court this would be an extending stands
which would cover the practice court
during events and so there would be
seating on both sides of this court and
there would be a clear span over this
entire area the university also wanted
to put a tower on top of the Fieldhouse
and in our proposal we decided that that
was a structurally ambitious thing that
we could avoid and we decided to avoid
it by organizing the Fieldhouse
differently we decided that we would use
modern technology in the form of of this
led game lines to reorganize the court
in such a way that you could have both
the competition court and the to
practice courts within the same space
and avoid the need to project beyond the
site of the project to below the tower
and then above that we located the
Student Center the strength and
conditioning center and then a small
research hub above that the as I said
the game the competition court looks
like this with seating all around and
it's very interesting because we did
this ultimately we were selected for the
project even though it was in violation
of the rules of the project which is the
perversity of competitions more likely
than not the winner has broken a rule an
important rule somewhere and in this
case when they saw the perspectives of
this space with people 360 around the
competition court they said they had to
have that and by breaking the rule this
is the practice courts and this was our
strategy and it's very interesting that
since we made this proposal the
technology of LED lighting for game
lines has now become mainstream
so that possibility exists so the notion
is that you would enter the
sports facilities from Allah beyond
itself and the Student Center from Allah
beyond the North this is the 360 seating
which proved to be instrumental in the
organization and selection of our
project not only that unlike the
university brief we raised the gymnasium
so that there is clear story lighting
all the way around which can be blacked
out but which allows you to from the
student lane and from the street and
from the two lobbies on either end to
overlook the basketball court and it's
really quite amazing the lane is only
about 20 feet wide and you look into
this enormous space it's it's a real
inversion of expectation and so going to
the Student Center moving up on the
North Lobby to the Student Center
interestingly enough the students who
were not really part part of the
selection process or part of the mandate
for this project ultimately decided that
they didn't want to be part of the
project and so when we move forward and
this is the strength and conditioning
center again overlooking the field when
we move forward they said there's no way
they wanted to be in a university you
know in a multi-purpose University
building because inevitably the
university would take over their face
and they wanted to be in a standalone
and so what we decided to do in that
regard was to and as a result of some
significant budget issues we moved that
part of the project we really
consolidated the research into a single
floor and so we were able to get a much
more compact and much more
cost-effective structure which allowed
us to move forward with the project
except for the wrinkle that Tower which
was supposed to be here which we had so
carefully avoided was compromised by the
redevelopment of a historical building
at this point for a very important donor
for the university the donor to make
this building work they need
like that like rout of Hall they needed
to add exit access and mechanical to the
building which they decided to do in
this location overlapping the footprint
of the proposed tower the argument that
they made was that these components
could be treated as temporary and that
at some future date when the tower went
forward they can be removed how you
remove the the elevator system the
mechanical system and the safety exiting
from a building was something that was
not discussed and obviously not
practical and so we were then charged
with how do you now solve the problem of
the tower and not only that the power
was held away so that Trust could get in
here to provide service for these four
buildings and there was only one
solution possible which was to construct
a turntable and trucks drive in and to
get turned around to deal with all the
servicing from these various buildings
and not only that this turntable
structure had to be designed in such a
way that it could support a tower of
some undescribed future character and so
the building that we were asked to
design the future Tower sat on part of
the large span trusses for the field
house and so here is the project under
construction in order to deal with the
clear span of two spaces below the
building is actually hung from a bridge
above and so under construction this is
the field house and here you see all of
the floors above the field house which
was just levitating above the space
being hung from these enormous trusses
which ultimately will and which we're
now commissioned to do to construct the
tower on top of and so here is the
project mass from varsity field this is
the sports and conditioning center which
you see here it's just opened and so we
were lucky to get in and get a few
photographs of
project and here in you are overlooking
the Fieldhouse okay
so part two I should say that our office
has always been engaged in architectural
research in the olden days when Tim was
in our office the research that we took
on was had to do with formal analysis
and so we would build models like this
one like this which Tim directed and
this one which Tim and I designed
together which were fragments of
projects that we'd designed with the
intention that they would be developed
in such a way that they would bring
forward the formal characteristics of
those projects in exaggerated and
perhaps more legible Matt in a perhaps
more legible manner since that time and
actually coincident with my teaching at
Yale we have radically transformed the
research that we've been doing what we
now are doing is full scale material
based research which looks at the
effects of material method manipulation
in terms of developing spaces and
structures and so the first is a project
which we were invited to participate in
which was to provide some shelters on a
frozen river in Winnipeg which is the
city which I grew up in in that would be
merely wind protection for the extreme
climate and the the hypothesis of this
project and all the subsequent projects
is that if you take a form material
either the net on the the red net or the
piece of plastic and deform it in some
way on the one hand with a chopstick on
the other hand with an elastic band you
begin to develop structure and you begin
to the health space and so we in
designing the shelters for the for the
river and we decided to work initially
in model form but we found that
that we were really unable to proceed
very far this way because in natural
fact we needed to be working with the
material from which we would be making
these things and so we moved immediately
to full size and we found to our
surprise that even the thinnest of
plywood didn't do what we needed to do
what we what the model had suggested
that we would do the thinness of plywood
had very little ability to bend partly
because of the fact that it's an
essentially an isotropic material that
is equally strong in both directions and
it wasn't large enough to construct the
volumes that we were attempted to make
and so we ultimately sourced the
material called bendy pipe Bend apply is
an anisotropic plywood it is very weak
in one axis and strong in another which
allows you to bend it in one axis very
radically it's made of very very heavy
cutter plies in a very in one direction
and very thin inner ply in the opposite
direction and what we found was we could
laminate various layers of Bend apply to
make larger pie and so we were then able
to make much bigger pieces out of these
multiple layers and still have material
that had the ability to bend and so here
we are working full size in the shop
within our office here you can see what
kind of Kercher's that we were able to
get out of this material and the fact
that we had two layers allowed us to
provide some interesting detailed
conditions which and here is the
full-size mock-up this was designed
simply by working directly with the
bendy ply at full size ultimately what
we did and you'll see in a moment so
here are here's the mock-up a number of
details were tested tried changed
replaced and ultimately we were able to
develop the mock-up the perforations
that you see reflect the fact that
there's only a single layer of Bend
apply in that location and here you gain
you can see how small-scale detailing of
these multiple layers and so what we did
was we built it we took it apart we
measured it we made drawings which you
see here
of this working in exactly the opposite
manner that we normally work as
architects even all of the connections
this is the base which is a timber base
these are this is the back spine and the
roof spine which tie the sheets together
these are the pieces that go together to
form these elements unpredictable shapes
because they were simply cut to achieve
the volumes that we wanted to create and
then opened up and we even studied it
again now going back into model form the
notion of how these might be clustered
and so we have the cluster and then the
fabrication and so the fit was
fabricated 1,500 miles away from our
office in this garage and the project
from our office went to the site to see
how they were coming especially in
response to a telephone call which he
received which had to do with this which
had to do with the fact that there were
some surprises and when he got there he
realized that what it happened was they
had ordered material that was twice as
thick as the design they thought they
could get it for the budget it would be
better but this is what happened to
solve that problem and this kind of
problem is not an unusual building
experience to solve this problem what we
decided to do was to weaken the plywood
in the areas of greatest curvature and
so in areas like this which really fold
around we simply scored the inside of
the sheets between the two layers we had
to trim some of the shapes which we
couldn't develop as much curvature as we
wanted we have to reinforce some of
they're really stressed locations with
sheet metal the net result of all of
that was that we got it built and in
some ways the added thickness made it
increasingly more robust and so here it
is out on the river these photographs
were taken by a very dear friend of mine
who has done most of our photography and
it was 35 below when he was shooting
this and he was trained by a salade
as a landscape photographer and so it's
all tripod work and everything you wait
for the perfect light and so he was out
in the field at 35 below sitting behind
his tripod doing these things well that
didn't last too long
very shortly into the adventure he threw
the tripod away and became the most
hated of photographers in his lexicon
the goggle photographer who points and
shoots and nevertheless he was able to
point and shoot quite a number of
beautiful photographs for us and not
only that he hung around to wait till to
get the key shot which is at 40 below
in the evening which was well worth the
wait
yeah well this work was all taking place
during the second term that I was
teaching here and I was teaching studio
which was located at the Eli Whitney
workshop and Museum just north of New
Haven and the director of the museum
William Brown said to me you know have
you seen this video called
between the folds it's all about origami
he said I really recommend that you see
it and I said folded birds had not
interested me but yeah I got the video
and there was one guy in the video his
name is Paul Jackson who is in Israel
and he related the anecdote where he was
asked by a student whether you can make
origami with one fold and he said no you
cannot make origami with one fold there
have been knows it takes a thousand
folds to make an elephant but he began
to think about that and he decided to
investigate the possibility of origami
with one fool and when I saw that I
thought to myself this is this is
remarkable how can we use this to make
structures and so we played with paper
in our office trying to master origami
developing all sorts of different forms
and ultimately we went into our low shop
and we took a piece of 24 gauge sheet
metal basically flashing her duck metal
and we scored a line on the metal and we
folded it and we cut a hole in the
middle of that score at this before we
folded it so that we could force the
thing and pop it around and this is
steel
and I took this piece of steel to a
number of steel fabricators in the city
and I said can you make this big and
they said absolutely what we will do is
well cut it as pieces we'll roll the
pieces on our rollers will weld it all
back together again and you
we'll you'll have that thing and I said
no I don't want that I want to get the
form that comes out of the process of
bending it of folding it makes with no
steel doesn't work like that paper works
like that but steel doesn't so we said
okay we'll take that on and so I had two
really really talented young guys in my
office who helped me with this and we
began to invent machines that would bend
steel like origami and so we and
ultimately we made six machines we
started out with this's machine number
two it's a very small machine we were
still bending sheep or flashing metal at
this point and here you see some of the
process where we banded the the metal we
went through six machines that this I
mean this was two people's work for four
months the research is not a modest
endeavor and ultimately came to this
machine number six or number five number
six and here you see it it almost
consumes the entire studio or the
courtyard outside of our studio this is
a five by 12 foot sized
16 gauge for I think 18 gauge sheet of
stainless steel so it's a very big piece
of steel we have a machine that's big
enough for it and we began to bend it
and the trick about our machine is that
it's broken in the middle and so as we
start tightening the bolts which drives
the two pieces of wood together if it
was if we had a shop it wouldn't be both
and it would be a hydraulic press but we
didn't have that but as we do that we
raise it and the break itself tapers
from a deep break to no break at the
same so there's really no depth where
where this fold is the it the mitten the
metal is still flat there and that's the
seat of the secret to this by folding it
wore
virtually not at all there and by
bending it as we're raising it and
typing it we're able to get this form
which is this and these forms are these
curves are completely natural vertical
curves that spring from the bending
operation this and so this was a
different material and a different
technique but the same operation as in
the skating shelters which is basically
sprung form where the material itself
takes on the curvature that is it that
it wants to take on as a result of the
forces that are applied to it and then
we projected this project which was
where we took the five by 12 sheet and
applied the same forces to a 24 by 10
sheet so one hundred percent larger and
you get this and it's actually a very
robust structure because not only is a
broken angle it's got the arch shapes as
well so it's very very stiff and a
surprisingly powerful natural form
shortly after finishing that work and
being quite excited about the result we
got a call from comme des Garcons from
this person great calico by Google and
Ray is a famous fashion designer here
she is with the dark glasses in the
whole nine yards a very extreme fashion
designer who is always on the edge who
owns conveying a saw there are a variety
of outlets and she said that she was
opening a new store in Ginza in Tokyo
and she loved the skinny shelters and
she wanted us to build some things that
she could use for display or for change
rooms or something in her new store in
Ginza and we said okay and she said one
thing it has to be fireproof because in
Tokyo fire is a huge issue and so we
said no problem because
we are steel masters and so we developed
this scheme which is basically taking
two of our won folds and tying them
together to form this structure which
would act either as a display structure
or as a change room with a suitable
modesty curtain
she said she didn't like it and she said
you didn't like it because it was too
artistic and I thought how could
something be too artistic but what can I
say
so she said she wanted something more
like the skating shelters and so okay
well the client is king I guess and so
we decided to try and explore steel in a
different way and so this is the design
that we developed and I should say that
these are plastic those are their models
are about this big and they're made out
of sheet plastic and they behave exactly
like steel they prove they're completely
predictive of the forms that the steel
sheets generate and so we looked at how
we had accomplished this measuring from
the full-scale wood what we decided to
do was to measure from the tiny scale
plastic and develop forms and here you
see the patterns that we developed off
of those tiny plastic models and you can
see that the modeling that the patterns
are beginning to become increasingly
fluid they're becoming more like
clothing and less like architecture
they're these are these are the fold
lines which this piece is tied to that
piece and so it goes together very much
like clothing like seams and the formal
language which again is something that
we take off the model and we develop
with all the bits and pieces that we
learned about doing the wood wound to
make them out of steel and so our
commission was to design and fabricate
and deliver these from Vancouver to
Tokyo and so here they are being
fabricated in Vancouver
we were lucky to get again to get a
great group of people who are really
interested in this and we began building
these things in the shop there were some
interesting adventures on route many of
the details that we developed worked out
perfectly some of them not so much the
first problem was we knew that there
would need to be some attention paid to
the edge because it was quite thin and
we were concerned not only about the
ability of somebody to cut themselves on
the edge but also what we learned in
this process was that in these very very
thin steel shells the edge and I think
this is true in all shells the edge is
where these the power of the shell
structure comes to an end and in a sense
the weakest point in a shell is the edge
and so typically what we found was you
had to reinforce the edge so the notion
was and a place and attach it to the
edge and that would accomplish the job
what we quickly under came to understand
was this thing is constantly twisting in
space and so a flat bar could not do
that and we were perplexed until the
simple idea of attaching a rod so we
packed on a half-inch steel rod and then
we grounded out and this is the edge
condition which is quite amazing because
it takes this unbelievably thin sheet
and gives it this soft sort of very
sensuous edge condition which you see
here we also had to make one of them
into a change room and so we were having
great difficulty and this is where we
blew the budget because they were
building this thing on the shop floor
before we'd figure out the door design
so we quickly built a wood version of
this thing in our shop and tried various
kinds of doors but nevertheless we
slowed them up in the shop floor and
ultimately paid the price but this is
the door which is a fabric over a steel
frame which is an in one of the two
shelters and so and finally because it
was an interior space with no natural
light we eliminated the
terior with a translucent floor which
you see here and so we've had to put it
all together but not only that because
it was going into a shop in Tokyo which
didn't have access from a service
elevator we had to take it apart on the
street in Tokyo carry it up in little
pieces off the stair and reassemble it
in the shop and so one of the problems
was that the pieces that we were had
made were bigger than the stairway that
we could carry it up in Tokyo and so how
do you break it down so here it is
broken down in pieces and the secret to
that is this right here what we found
was that there was one place where there
was a straight line on the face of the
curving plane and at that point we made
a cut and we made a fold and then we
could make a joint and so we could break
that large piece down into two pieces
and that ability of that straight line
that ruled surface became very
instrumental in subsequent projects and
so I'm just gonna blow through these
things but it was quite a little piece
of industrial design and the end result
is remarkably monumental sort of
enigmatic form and not only is it have a
monumental appearance it has an
unbelievably robust surface even though
it's very thin material the curved shape
and the edge conditions make it turn it
into a very very tough thing and here it
is in the shop so moving from the notion
of that to our real objective which is
to make these research projects
architectural and scale to get them big
we began to look at the whole notion of
ruled surfaces and what that could
develop and so as a hypothetical project
we developed the notion that we would
design two retaining walls which would
construct a cut through the landscape
joining two pieces of park land that was
separated by
Photography and vegetation and what we
did was we decided that the
configuration of these retaining walls
would be undulating intensely at the
bottom of the wall and undulating in a
very gentle curve at the top of the wall
so that we would have an inherent
structural strength through the shape
and the idea was that we would make a
series of triangular trusses which here
you see them all lined up and each one
is just a triangle with some
cross-training between and onto those
trusses we would make some CNC cut
guides on to which we would lay in a
whole series of two by fours and these
two by fours would simply be sitting in
the guides and on to that we would add
reinforcement and guy and so basically a
swimming-pool type structure on this and
then simply remove the wood structure
from the interior and these are the
spaces and the robust structure that
results from the undulating geometry and
the single sided formwork which acts to
construct this space and again shows
sort of the power of simply taking
dimensional lumber at a large scale and
using it through a very simple mechanism
like a ruled surface having done that we
then said well how do we start scaling
up the metal that we're working on and
we had taken our machine and gone to
fabricators and they've always resisted
using our machine because they don't
believe that they can predict and
control the outcome and so we decided to
go back to a much more rudimentary idea
which is that you simply fold steel in a
conventional break so that any of these
forms can be made in any shop simply by
folding pieces of steel and joining them
together and using this idea we could
then start stacking them which you can
see over here and construct
tower-like forms and the notion was that
we would then construct something and we
said well let's call it cooling station
the idea
that there was a Foundation which was
isolated from the ground so that it was
the earth temperature there was a
reflective stainless steel tower which
has painted black at the top and grating
to reflective at the bottom we would
then have some thermal sync embedded in
a double layer at the top and so the
combination of the radiant cooling and
the stack that we create would construct
a completely passive cooling station for
hot desert conditions and so this is the
design that we developed all in the
interests of constantly finding ways
which we can begin to scale these things
up to get into building size currently
we're working on a project for a friend
of mine who used to teach architecture
at the University of British Columbia
before and he wanted a place just to
have a drink in his garden and so we
took our one fold machine we said well
here's the sucker here's somebody who's
going to go and spring for the one fold
and so we developed this form using one
fold
elements and I know written Andrews got
tons of cash and so why couldn't he do
this and so we took this design to metal
shops and they said no problem we can do
this for you we'll cut it into pieces
we'll roll it we'll weld it all back
together and it'll only cost one hundred
and fifty thousand dollars well andrew
didn't go for that and so we went back
to the drawing board and we decided that
we would go back to this notion of
simply folding simple sheets in a
conventional way in a simple steel break
and we began to play so the first one we
did had a fold and a fold
tie these two sheets together and tied
to the ground the third fold to try and
get some more structural behavior we
went through a whole series of these
things ultimately coming to this guy
which has some some important conditions
the folds that are attached to the
ground or a very important structure
these two folds form a triangle which
becomes an incredibly robust structural
element and then and this is made a very
very thin material so it's it
unbelievably floppy if you you can take
it to just shake it and it just goes
like like almost like and so that was
the beginning here are two sheets they
were they're made of the the garden
gnome that we ultimately developed is
made of four sheets of five by twelve
stainless steel 16 gauge each sheet has
three folds which you see here the folds
are turned into this sort of v-shaped
figure when you put those two together
in this situation and then you fold them
back on themselves and attach them to
the ground they give you this figure and
when you take two of them and you nest
them and then you take the then
reconcile point at the top and pull them
together and weld them that introduces a
stress which brings the top of the
structure into attention so that the
robustness of the triangle at the bottom
is not equalled but is approached by
this added stress that's been added and
so then you get this element which we
were able to build for $30,000 which was
Andrews upset limit and so three folds
four sheets of steel and you get this
form okay last project this is the this
was an ideas competition one of the
students here that was in my studio
Jackie Howe was a member of our team
working on this project the idea was
that we would take the forming system
that we used
for the rift and turn it into a
structure so what you see is that each
piece of wood is simply moved slightly
in plane and so you get this form so
this is made entirely out of straight
pieces these are steel cones at the top
but all these curved surfaces are made
entirely of straight pieces there are
remarkable structure because each they
are scabbed together with these joints
and they're made of regular modular
modules of woods when they are all made
out of very conventional lengths and
they begin to act as a shell and the key
to the structure unlike Joyce or beams
where wood is limited in its span by
virtue of its depth here we're limited
in span by virtue of the curvature of
the overall shell and so we begin to get
some remarkable spans really remarkable
spans and the ability to do some very
interesting things which have a
remarkably free dimensional quality made
entirely out of straight sections and so
here are the plans it was a small branch
library so there's a reading terrorists
auditorium this is the reception
there's some offices in back-of-house
the stacks above and the mezzanine above
that and this is the section through the
building and you'll note when they look
at the sections that in one direction
the sections are made entirely out of
straight pieces and that's because those
sections are cut perpendicular or
parallel to the members which make up
these these shapes and so the gay
everything is straight but as soon as
you rotate 90 degrees and you may cut
through this form remarkable curvatures
and curving planes which come simply out
of the a bunch of company a slight
adjustment of adjacent members of would
significantly beams that span from here
to here because we have a shell we have
a shell that does that and so you're
able to do enormous structures using
wood in a completely efficient way
another of these sections our projection
for the exterior was cement issues
coating and ceramic tile in retrospect I
don't think that's the best solution for
this material I think the metal shingle
is the most natural cladding system for
it here you can even see that this
system allows you to rotate planes out
you can construct Gila like openings
from the interior to the exterior and so
some of the perspectives of the interior
of this space again all of these are
reciprocal structures made of small
short members all tied together to
function as a shell
thank you John will you take some
questions all right we have some
questions for our speaker tonight it's a
minute
such quiet
are you intending to realize this
project alas was that ideas coming I did
but now we're looking to do that well I
should say that we have about four other
research projects ongoing in the office
right now which are exploring quite
different operations some some of them
are surprising and if it wasn't for
intellectual property concerns I would
show that share them with you but we're
actually beginning to get to understand
that this activity is taking so much of
our time well I was gonna ask that as a
simple a simple capitalist that I am
yeah well who's paying for all this
exactly that's nobody's paying for it
and that's a problem but the notion is
that this is all scalable it all goes to
architectural scale it all can be
applied to projects yes there's a
question we'll get the microphone to you
please hi I just wanted to ask what
inspires you to start these research
projects because they're quite different
from one another
yeah there it's there there's a it's a
combination of things in the first
instance my partner Patricia was a
full-time professor at University of
British Columbia so she was in the
office a couple days of the week but she
was teaching the rest of the week and
about five years ago four years ago when
we began just before we began these
things she decided that she was going
from full-time teaching and when she did
that I said great
because we need you like I'm really
happy they're gonna be in the office all
the time and she said hang on
I'm not coming into office any more than
I currently am I'm doing that I'm using
that time to be something but anyway and
so the first thing that she did was she
responded to the invitation that we'd be
given to do the Winnipeg skinny
shoulders and she began playing with it
and the second she began playing with it
I was there because it looked like so
much fun and and James who was the
project was as well and we it
immediately became something that the
office was really enthusiastic about and
the potential for it was obvious
so her sort of refusal to accept sort of
the grind was one part of the impetus
for it the other part was the reason why
she refused simply to come into the
office full-time was because of the
frustration that we have and I think
most practicing art is to have with the
challenges of doing a practice in
architecture I mean it's filled with
frustration it's filled with the
challenge I mean you've got budgets that
are always too low you could clients who
always make the wrong decision you've
got building officials and I know
there's a building official here who's
always giving you a grief but it's but
there is an edit and it's really
interesting a very good friend of mine
who was trained as an architect and who
worked for me briefly he has now got an
industrial design practice and he was
playing back and forth between
industrial design and architecture
and he's a totally engaging guy and
could he could sell anybody anything and
so he could be a translation successful
architect but he said you know when I do
industrial design the only thing I hear
is yes every time I propose something
they say yes I would do that actually
see that yes please and he says when I'm
an architect everything I always hear is
no you can't do that for this reason
can't do that for this
you can't do that so there is this
problem and we have not abandoned
architecture as as a practice because
the rewards are sometimes worth the
effort but the but the ability to
develop your own project and that's why
I made the distinction at the outside of
the lecture building projects are
commissioned by clients research
projects are often something that we
simply invent we get to decide when it's
good enough we get to decide what it
costs we get to decide all of those
things and the freedom that that has
given us has been and the gratification
that we've gotten from it has been
remarkable and I think in a sense it
hasn't undermined the architectural
practice because you would you unlike
the my friend who is the industrial
designer who says no architectures is
too frustrating for us it's really
energized the architectural practice
because we now see a whole sort of line
of development at an orchestral scale
which is really exciting for us may not
be for others but for us it's very
exciting and so it's proved to be a
almost rejuvenator for a practice that's
been a lot around for a long time and so
we are now trying to bring all of that
knowledge and process and a different
way of developing projects into the
mainstream of our office and certainly
our offices of big studio space where
everybody sees all of this stuff and
sees these things being made and cried
not everybody is participating in them
because somebody has to earn money but
but it really has been good for the
office and so it's proved to be I think
a real shot
of energy for us is thank you yes thank
you John for the beautiful lecture it
was so interesting to me to see the
houses and how they change from place to
place and so I'm wondering as they're so
different is there anything in your mind
that makes them the same yes I think
they all share scale for us we are we
are very concerned to keep the scale of
the projects human scale is meaningless
but what we're really concerned about
intimacy but this projects not becoming
overblown so scale is a is one thing
that is is it the same in all the
projects but because the project is so
formally and materially different you
don't necessarily perceive that I think
the response to the topography of the
site is a characteristic of all those
projects the way in which we use natural
light is the same I mean they're all of
the in sort of the intangibles are the
same it's the tangible dimensions of the
project which change and and really I
think it's the intangibles which are
what you're really trying to create
that's the objectives in the end and so
that is constant through the projects
for more questions well thank you I'll
join Dewey saying it was a beautiful
lecture and inspiring and let's that
poor guy you've made that thing he can't
barely lift a glass in that shelter oh
really
are you sure enough for ya okay
rule tested upstairs